- [Voiceover] We are about to be forced
to compliment each other on camera.
- Wow, I just need to admit
this is really awkward.
- Oh this is hard to think about.
- That's not weird at all.
- Max and I do give each
other compliments a lot.
- But this is the opposite
of what we're used to doing.
- It's weird making eye contact.
(jazzy music)
(laughing)
- You're really great with people.
- I think you have a lot of joy in you
and it's pretty infectious.
- Can you just look the other way?
- Okay, I'll look over here.
- The other way.
- Alright.
- I feel like we're doing wedding vows.
- Caleb's personality is
rock solid in conflict.
- He's honest and there all the time.
- You have great gravitas.
- Thank you.
- Is that a compliment?
- You're very enthusiastic.
- You are a very deep thinker.
- Ah, I like that a lot.
- I think that counts as personality.
- That was great.
- Your personality, it's very bubbly.
- Zack is that shinning bright light.
- We're like kindred dry spirits.
(laughing)
- Justin's got great biceps.
Have I openly told you that?
- He's has a really classic
kind of beauty in his face.
- You have a decent face.
- Really symmetrical features.
- Look at him.
Look at him ladies.
What's not to like?
- [Voiceover] Your eyes are
two colors, which I like.
Right?
- Are they really?
- I don't know what to say.
- I've seen you with your shirt off
and you are more fit than you appear
on the outside of your clothes.
- Nice.
That's what I'm going for.
- He's got a great upper
body and great jaw line.
When you can see it.
- And your smattering of body hair
also makes you more manly looking.
- Smattering.
- If I'm gonna go out and
we're gonna hit on some ladies
Max is like the bringer.
- I think you have really great posture.
- A very attractive man.
I mean look at him, look at this face.
- My butt was clenched the entire time.
- It's a little weird.
- I would say at first
a little uncomfortable.
But we eased into it.
- There's that male thing.
It's like, "Oh that's weird,
you shouldn't do that".
- It felt good.
- It does feel good.
- We're just gonna trash
on each other after this.
- I think all guys out there
should go and compliment
their guy friend right now.
- We should do this more often.
Because sometimes you're down.
Sometimes we get down on ourselves.
- I think Eugene is very straight forward
and I really appreciate that
in a co-worker and a friend.
- I guess Andrew's my friend now.
- I guess we're friends.